our story begins in the summer of 1940.
the people of western europe were in a
profound state of shock
in just a few weeks nazi germany with
blinding speed
had invaded and occupied six countries
knocking them over like dominoes
one of them was belgium seventeen days
after german troops
poured over belgian's border its
government surrendered
but the hero of our story did not
surrender
her name is andre dejong she was known
as didi in the belgian capital of
brussels
didi's father a school master named paul
de jong
burst into tears when he told his 23
year old daughter
about the government's capitulation she
had never seen her father cry before
and it made her not only sad but very
angry
not at him but at the germans she told
her father
you are wrong to cry you'll see what we
do to them
her spirit of defiance was very unusual
in occupied europe in those early days
of world war
ii most europeans were still
totally overwhelmed by what had just
happened
they had no idea how to react much less
fight back at that point the german
occupiers
seemed all-powerful the main goal of
most people under their control was
simply to survive
but that was not good enough for didi
dejong
from the very beginning she was
determined to resist
just a year after belgium's occupation
she had become one of the top resistance
leaders in europe
she began her work in brussels shortly
after the belgian surrender
these are the kind of people i'm going
to focus on in these lectures
people i've encountered in my research
who are unsung heroes
who made a difference in world war ii
but who are unknown to most people
and who have never been given the credit
they deserved
several of them in addition to dede are
women
dede was a commercial artist by
profession but when belgium was invaded
she started working as a nurse for
british troops wounded in the fighting
there
along with a group of friends and
acquaintances she began to smuggle
injured british soldiers out of
german-controlled hospitals
and take them to nearby safe houses that
she had set up
not long afterwards she traveled
secretly to spain
which during world war ii was a neutral
country
there she met with british officials she
told them that many british servicemen
were still hiding in belgium
some were soldiers others were airmen
shot down on recent bombing missions
in the past few months she said she
along with several friends of hers had
set up an escape line through belgium
and france
to help these men get back to england
if the british government would give her
money to help pay for the line
for guides safe houses food and train
fares
she could bring out these men but she
made clear
that the escape line would have to
remain under her control
at first the british were skeptical it
seemed unlikely to them that this petite
slender young woman
had traveled from german-occupied
belgium
through occupied france and over the
dizzying heights of the pyrenees
mountains to spain
eventually however they verified her
story
and agreed to finance her operation
that gamble paid off in a big way
by the time the war was over dijon's
escape network
which was called the comet line would be
the largest
and most important escape line in
occupied europe
it would be credited with rescuing more
than 800 british and american servicemen
getting them out of enemy territory and
back to freedom
there were a number of other networks
like the comet line throughout europe
but they were most active in three
countries
belgium france and holland
starting in 1941 allied bombers flew
over these countries
on their daily bombing missions between
england and germany
a sizable number of the planes were shot
down during those flights
but when they were many crew members
were able to parachute out before the
planes crashed
which left them stranded behind enemy
lines
at a time when trained bomber crews were
in desperately short supply
it was vital for the allied war effort
to rescue as
many of these airmen as possible and
bring them back to england
to continue the fight the comet line
worked mostly in belgium and france the
headquarters of the line was in brussels
and then it snaked its way south through
france to the pyrenees mountains
which lay on the border of france and
spain
it worked somewhat like an assembly line
stranded allied airmen
when they were found were taken to the
closest safe house
which usually was in a village or on a
farm
then they were taken to collection
points in brussels and paris
from there they were escorted hundreds
of miles by comet line workers
to a chain of safe houses in the
foothills of the pyrenees
from that point spanish guides escorted
them over the mountains to spain
and from there they returned to england
members of the comet line network came
from a wide variety of backgrounds and
occupations
ranging from students to aristocrats to
factory workers
many of them were in their teens and
twenties
and as was true for other escape lines
the majority of comet line workers
couriers guides and operators of safe
houses
were women being part of an escape
network
was probably the most dangerous form of
resistance work
in europe german officials were keenly
aware of the value of these airmen to
the allied bombing effort
and they ordered the escape lines to be
crushed
using any means necessary
for escape line workers the danger of
capture was
ever present and the penalty for their
work was
far more severe than that faced by the
men they were hiding
if allied servicemen were captured they
were sent to prisoner
of war camps where geneva convention
rules applied
but when escape line members were caught
they faced torture
the horrors of a nazi concentration camp
and or execution
it was particularly dangerous for the
couriers
most of them young women many of them
still in their teens
who escorted the servicemen hundreds of
miles across
enemy territory these women did their
work
out in the open riding on trains and
other forms of public transportation
with young men who clearly were not
european
as one british intelligence officer
observed
it is not an easy matter to hide a
foreigner in your midst
especially when it happens to be a
red-haired scotsman
or a gum-chewing american from the
middle west finding clothes to fit
americans who tended to be considerably
taller than britons or other europeans
was a particular problem so was finding
enough food
at a time when food was increasingly
scarce for everyone
in europe sometimes american airmen on
the run
had a hard time understanding why they
were given so little to eat
that was because they were coming from a
country that had very little experience
dealing with the shortages caused by war
british airmen were less demanding
because their own country had been
strictly rationed
since 1940. british airmen were also
considered calmer and more disciplined
than their american counterparts who
were more independent
and outgoing and sometimes less willing
to accept the orders of these young
women
who were guiding them to freedom before
they set out
on these extremely dangerous journeys
comet line workers did their best to
teach the young men they were guiding
how to blend in while in public
in one case a bowlegged texan was
instructed in the fine art
of walking like a european since most of
the airmen spoke only english
they were ordered to keep quiet at all
times in public
american airmen were told to keep their
hands out of their pockets
which was a particularly american trait
and they were coached on the way
europeans use silverware when eating
keeping their fork in their left hand
rather than shifting it back and forth
like americans do during a meal
both britain's and americans were told
never to smoke cigarettes produced in
their own countries
the smoke had an odor significantly
different
from that of european cigarettes and
they could never be seen with a bar of
chocolate
which was impossible to find in occupied
europe during the war
as the men were repeatedly told the
slightest mistake could draw the
attention of one of the many
french belgian and german security
officials
who patrolled buses trains and other
forms of public transportation
after the war the airmen who were saved
by members of the comet line
spoke very movingly about the
selflessness and courage of their
rescuers
one of them was an englishman named bob
frost
who as a nineteen-year-old sergeant was
escorted to
spain by didi dejong herself in the
autumn of 1942.
speaking of dede and her colleagues
frost said
i fell in love with them totally
absolutely
they knew the price if they were caught
it was heroism beyond anything i can
tell you
when the airmen returned to england they
were questioned by
officials from mi9 which was a small
clandestine government agency
created to help rescue allied servicemen
trapped behind enemy lines
mi9 was run by two young british army
officers
james langley and arie neve who knew
from personal experience what these men
had gone through
both langley and neve had fought against
the germans in france
during the late spring of 1940 both had
been stranded behind enemy lines
and both had been helped by newly formed
escape networks
when they returned to england they were
asked to join mi9
which provided money and radio
communications to those involved
in running the escape lines
when langley and neve questioned
returning airmen about their escape
experiences
they recalled how these men's eyes
filled with tears
when talking about deedee and her
associates
arie neve remembered how afraid they
were for her
he and langley felt the same way
they both were well aware that the
bigger an escape line became
the more vulnerable it was it became
virtually impossible to check out the
backgrounds of the hundreds of people
who worked on the escape lines or the
airmen who used them to get back to
england
as a result it's not surprising that the
germans had considerable success
in infiltrating the lines with agents
impersonating allied airmen
most of these impersonators were german
citizens who had lived in britain or the
united states
for long periods and who spoke fluent
english
to help their credibility with the
escape lines they were equipped with
documents
and dog tags that had been recovered
from killed or captured britain's or
americans
the germans were also aided by french
belgian and english collaborators
who joined the lines as workers
knowing all this james langley and erie
neve
wanted to send a radio operator to
brussels to help dede communicate
directly with london
rather than relying on meetings with
british liaison officers in spain
with a radio connection she would have
been able to alert mi9
immediately in case of trouble and mi9
could let her know
about possible traitors and german
agents posing as helpers of allied
airmen
but didi said no right from the
beginning
she had made it clear that while she
would accept financial help from the
british
they would have no say in the actual
operation of the comet line
as langley recalled dede insisted to him
and neve that quote the decisions always
rested with the men
and women in the field the line was
belgian
it would be run by belgians and any help
would be gratefully received
but the payment of money was simply a
reimbursement of expenses
and in no way gave us the right to issue
orders unquote while langley and neve
never stopped worrying about dede they
had to admit
she knew what she was doing she was
involved
in every aspect of the operation she
organized the safe houses
worked with photographers and forgers to
produce false belgian and french
identity papers
and personally guided dozens of airmen
to the spanish frontier
and over the pyrenees she was known
to american and british airmen under her
care as the postmistress
because she referred to them very
affectionately
as her parcels her real identity was
kept a closely guarded secret
from the time of the comet line's
creation in 1941
there had been numerous arrests of its
workers
but deedee herself managed to elude the
nazis for more than 18 months
langley and neve who knew how determined
the germans were to smash the line
were afraid that her luck was running
out
they urged her and her father who worked
closely with her
to come to england before it was too
late
but as always she kept to her own rules
refusing even to consider the thought of
leaving
in early january 1943 didi dejong
set off with three american pilots on
her 18th trip to spain a heavy snowstorm
caught them just before they crossed the
pyrenees
and they were forced to seek shelter for
the night at a safe house in the
foothills of the mountains
the next morning the gestapo acting on a
tip from a local
farm worker burst into the house and
arrested all its occupants
allied airmen were repeatedly warned
that if they were captured
they must not reveal the identities and
locations of those who had hidden or
otherwise helped them
their only obligation they were told was
to give their name
rank and serial number just as if they
had been captured in combat
but the harshness of gestapo
interrogation
proved too much for some including one
of the pilots who was caught with dede
he gave up the names of his guides and
the owners of the safe houses
who had sheltered him while the three
pilots were sent to a pow
camp dede and those who helped her
vanished without a trace
they were among the tens of thousands of
political prisoners in occupied europe
who under a decree from hitler
disappeared into what was
called the knight and fog of nazi
concentration camps
a few weeks later the gestapo again
struck hard at comet
this time arresting nearly 100 of its
operatives in brussels and
elsewhere in belgium before that
happened however
a pretty 28 year old friend and close
associate of deities
named peggy van leer was smuggled out of
belgium
by fellow comet agents and taken to
gibraltar
where she was sent by plane to london
there james langley was waiting to greet
her
he was instantly smitten by the
red-haired blue-eyed belgian
falling in love with her he later told
friends the moment she stepped off the
plane
the two were married the following year
had five children
and lived happily together in suffolk
for the rest of their lives
peggy van leer was lucky to get out when
she did
the first gestapo raid was followed by a
second one
several months later this one triggered
by a french collaborator
working for the gestapo in paris didi
dejong's father
who was head of the line in paris was
rounded up
along with her sister and dozens of
other associates
most of them including paul de jong were
later executed
as james langley later said it seemed
incredible that comet could survive
but survive it did despite the loss of
its founder and so many other key
members
the network was able to rebuild itself
enlisting the help of new couriers and
guides
setting up more safe houses and
maintaining the flow of allied
servicemen back to england
an estimated 3000 civilians mostly
belgians and french
worked with the comet line about 700
were arrested by the germans
and 290 were executed or died in prison
or concentration camps nonetheless
the line was able to continue its rescue
operations until belgium was liberated
in the fall of 1944 of the 800
servicemen
that the comet lines saved in its three
years of existence
118 were escorted to spain
by didi dejong herself
by the end of the war the rescue of
downed allied airmen
had become a commonplace event in all
some seven
thousand british american and other
allied servicemen
were spirited out of occupied europe
during the war
the number of those who helped them
escape has been estimated at more than
12
000 people during the war allied fighter
and bomber crews were briefed on how to
evade capture
and seek out rescuers if they were shot
down
they were given a compass silk maps of
the countries they were flying over
and other emergency supplies to keep
them going while they were looking for
help
if they were shot down they were told
their first objective was to get rid of
their parachute
and leave their landing spot as soon as
possible
as the war progressed those goals became
increasingly easy to achieve
whenever the thunder of planes was heard
in belgium
holland or northern france crowds of
people would gather outside to watch the
planes fly overhead
if parachutes were seen those observers
would hop on their bicycles
or run in the parachute's direction in
the hope of getting there before the
germans
in february 1943 an american pilot shot
down on his way back from a raid on the
french port of san nazaire
was spirited away by several women who
raced up to him
as he landed in august of that year
two american sergeants down near
brussels were each greeted by crowds of
several dozen belgians
and passed on to escape lines that same
month
another u.s sergeant who was shot down
near the french town of toulouse
was swarmed by some 30 frenchmen as he
drifted to the ground
they immediately removed his parachute
and uniform
and gave him civilian clothes to put on
in four minutes he said i look like any
one of the frenchmen who had rescued me
and my flying suit and equipment had
disappeared
many years after the war a belgian woman
who spent more than three years in a
german concentration camp
for helping the escape of downed allied
flyers
said that she never regretted the heavy
price that she
and other members of the belgian
resistance paid for helping the allied
cause
as she put it the airmen who come for
reunions
feel they can't thank us enough we say
if it wasn't for the english we might be
german now
she was one of the lucky ones who
survived
so as it turned out was dede de jean
after her capture didi had been sent to
a prison in paris
and then to the infamous ravensbruck
concentration camp
the only german camp designed
specifically for women
which was located north of berlin of the
132
000 women and children sent there during
the war
more than 70 percent died of starvation
torture beating hanging shooting
horrific
medical experiments and beginning in
november 1944
in a newly installed gas chamber
deedee was close to dying herself by the
time robin's brook was liberated in the
spring of 1945.
she owed her survival she later said to
the german's
stereotype view of women coming from a
very traditional
patriarchal society they viewed women
chiefly in their conventional
domestic roles as wives and mothers
so even when dede after her capture
freely admitted to creating the comet
line
she managed to avoid execution because
the germans could not
bring themselves to believe that such a
pretty
delicate looking young woman could have
devised such an intricate operation
she later told an interviewer women have
such an
innocent look you know they look so
terribly harmless
germans are not accustomed to women with
opinions of their own
when the war was over a number of
british groups military and civilian
organized annual reunions to celebrate
their wartime bonds with the europeans
with whom they had worked
among those groups was the raf escaping
society
which was sponsored and financed by the
british air ministry
as a way of paying tribute to the
thousands of europeans who had helped
rescue
downed allied airmen the society
provided financial assistance to the
families of escape network members who
had been killed by the germans
and to members requiring medical
treatment or who were otherwise
in need it also helped sponsor reunions
between the airmen
and those who aided them year after year
the most heavily attended gathering
was the reunion celebrating the work of
dede dejong's comet line
didi herself was regarded as a heroine
by the hundreds of britons and americans
whom she and her network had saved
following the war she was awarded the
u.s medal of freedom
and the british george medal both of
them high civilian honors
but she was never comfortable in the
spotlight
for most of the rest of her life she
devoted herself
once again to saving the lives of others
working first as a nurse in a leper
colony in the belgian congo
and then at a leper hospital in ethiopia
but the men she rescued during the war
never forgot her
a few years after the war ended
britain's royal air force
showed its appreciation for what she had
done in a very special way at that time
she was working in the ethiopian capital
of addis ababa she had been told that
her mother was on her deathbed in
belgium
but she had no way to get there quickly
when raf officials learned of the
situation
they ordered a training flight from
africa to britain
to make an unscheduled stop in addis
ababa
the plane picked her up and in another
unscheduled leg of the flight took her
to brussels
after her mother's funeral yet another
raf plane
returned her to ethiopia
from the beginning of her life to the
end didi dejong
was in the words of an airman she saved
one of those rare beings who felt the
misery of the world
and would not let it rest
[Music]
you